Olha essa que acabou de sair. Você sabia
que não existe porção segura de carne
processada? Nem uma fatia de presunto
por dia? Pois é, um estudo da
Universidade de Washington analisou 78
pesquisas anteriores e chegou numa
conclusão bem direta. Uma única porção
de área de salsicha, presunto, mortadela
ou bacon já aumenta em 11% o risco diabé
tipo 2, em 7% o risco de câncer
intestinal. E olha, estamos falando só
de carnes ultra processadas, não das
carnes frescas que você compra no seu
açogue, ok? A diferença tá nos
conservantes químicos, nos nitritos e
nitratos que essas indústrias jogam para
aumentar a validade. Esses compostos
causam inflamação no organismo e podem
levar mutações celulares. Veja bem, não
é alarmismo, é ciência pura. Na próxima
vez que for no supermercado, repensa
aquela copra do embutido e investe numa
carne fresca. que o seu corpo vá
agradecer a longo prazo.